I am pleased to welcome to the platform
the Honorable Walter L Sullivan mayor of
the city of Cambridge and mr. Kenneth H
Olsen founder and president of Digital
Equipment Corporation mr. Olsen will now
give the address thank you when I
graduated from MIT I'm not sure we could
pronounce the word entrepreneur today
entrepreneurs the hot word among young
people it's a challenging word
fascinating word in the next 20 minutes
I'll try to tell you what I learned over
30 years on entrepreneurship we received
a good education at MIT a surprisingly
pertinent education I can even say I
learned double-entry bookkeeping from
Samuelson's Economics book but there was
one thing missing we were never taught
any theory of work any philosophy of
work anything about job satisfaction and
what to look for edge shine professor of
industrial psychology at the Sloan
School once said
the job was the most important thing in
a person's life and yet the job was one
thing we very rarely talk about I can in
20 minutes
answer that need but not of ownership
does give an interesting vehicle around
which to think about one's job and one's
goals in a job
the place of entrepreneurship and
society is obvious the traditional
enterprises do not or will not or
reluctant to try new ideas new
approaches to gamble to risk to play
them to pay the price for competition
it's a place of the entrepreneur to
introduce new ideas new products new
approaches few entrepreneurs survive
very long either because they're
successful or because they fail but out
of many approaches comes good like with
evolution with many attempts better
things arrived when I left MIT 30 years
ago I had attained just about everything
I had dreamed for I had an opportunity
to much more research much more elegant
research with much more resources than I
had ever dreamed at $12,000 a year I was
able to feed my family and I had
everything that I wanted but one thing
was missing nobody cared the industrial
world didn't care what we were doing
they said we were too academic I'm
afraid that's what we say to MIT
sometime today we
felt we had to prove something to the
world and we wanted to try our dream oh
we had a dream at that time which was
demonstrated at at MIT and that was the
place of interactive computing normal
computing at the time was considered big
expensive awesome beyond ordinary people
interactive computing was exciting fun
people could interact directly with the
computer and we had demonstrated the
usefulness of this at MIT and it was our
dream to show the world what it could do
at MIT we saw a it worked in a trusting
atmosphere a generous attitude and at
the same time an enormous ly competitive
intellectual atmosphere which was very
productive and great fun there was a
team spirit which meant that everyone
knew what the goals were and everybody
worked together towards them we had
technical ideas to demonstrate but we
also wanted to prove that this same
environment could work outside of MIT we
went to American research and
development corporation just across the
river in Toa we want to start a company
this was not the right time a recession
was starting electronic companies
started during the Korean War we're not
doing well but they were fascinated and
in time they asked us to make a
presentation to their board and they
gave us three pieces of advice first
they said don't use the word computer
because Fortune magazine said no one was
making money at it or they're about to
so we took the word out of our proposal
the lesson there is of course you have
to be adaptable
secondly they suggested that 5% profit
was not enough for people to risk their
capital on you see we had studied in the
Lexington library all good companies and
they all seemed to make 5% profit so we
promised 10% now the lesson and we made
10% most of the time the lesson there of
course is obvious if you aim throw a
high goal you might not make it but if
you aim for a low go low goal you're
surely aren't going to make a high goal
and then we were told that we should
promise fast results because most of the
board was over 80 so we promised to make
a profit in a year and the lesson there
is of course just like with a home
budget if you don't have short goals
you're encouraged to spend more money
than you're taking in they bought our
plan and they gave us $70,000 nice thing
about $70,000 is you can watch every
single dollar for the $70,000
they had seventy more than 70 percent of
the company and with that they gave us
freedom and they didn't interfere when
things were going poorly they didn't
interfere to straighten us out when
things were going well they didn't
interfere to exploit what was going well
they did have a long term interest in
the good of the company and the good of
the country we never finished our
business plan we didn't have a big book
filled with spreadsheets and colored
graphs we did have simple profit loss
statements and balance sheets and when
American research could see that these
financial plans were in our head and in
our hearts that we made them that we
understood them we remembered them and
they were simple enough simple enough to
be a model for us to run a company on
they committed to make the investment
and never did ask for a beautiful bow
proposal today when plans are made by
computer or by staff they have more
detail than one can keep in their head I
sometimes fear that the elegant
mathematics of a P&L statement and
balance sheet loses its usefulness when
people put too much detail into it today
when someone would leave us to become an
entrepreneur as I'm saying goodbye to
them I will sometimes say when you say
your prayers at night
pray for your P&L statement if your P&L
statement is not so simple you can
remember every line if it's not yours
it's not your in your heart you don't
know what you want and you don't know
what your plans are so far a few people
have taken that advice we learned a lot
we moved into an old mill and paid 25
cents a square foot per year for space
with watchman service and heat we move
the furniture ourselves we built the
walls and partitions we did the
photography in my basement we printed
circuit boards with real silk on wooden
frames edge statement aquarium tanks
from the 5 and 10 sometimes we spill the
edging solution on the furniture store
below I think we bought the same
furniture several times we learned the
counting and all the steps of
manufacturing and all of this was good
education developed a sensitivity for a
whole organization when we first met
with our accountants we told them we
want a big company accounting and our
very humble office with lawn furniture
and a leftover roll top desk it took a
lot of convincing to let them know we
really wanted to become the Accounting
when we finally had the system set up we
discovered it cost more to do than the
manufacturing did
but after we're in business for 12
months we did make a profit
not much but a profit we very proudly
took our statement down across the river
to general Daurio president of American
research and gave him our statement he
looked at them and looked up and scowled
and he said no one has ever succeeded
this soon and survived the challenge was
obvious he had watched many people start
companies over many years and success is
almost completely destructive of
entrepreneurial spirit it stops one from
taking risks one delegate delegate the
financial statements to staff or a
computer and one loses the humility
necessary to learn the traditions of
science and indeed the church have been
that humility is necessary to learn to
explore to search for the truth today
much of science and the church to feel
that any humility any lack of
self-confidence will make it hard to get
money and without money there's no
science or no church however it seems to
me that the humility that comes with a
spirit of learning probing experimenting
trying doing redoing and redoing again
is the only way to improve most things
and particularly the world of elegant
technology after a small number of years
we had to face the question of how to
introduce entrepreneurship throughout
the company we were doing well we had
gone to be a 14 million dollar company
no one wanted to make changes but we
were a company of people full of ideas
of what other people should do
full of ideas where we should spend
money what products we should do and it
was only one entrepreneur to keep it all
in in perspective we then broke the
company into a number of entrepreneurial
product lines each one had complete
responsibility for his segment of
business and everybody else was there
just to service these product lines many
of the people quit some of the board
left us it's not easy to make changes
when things are going well everyone felt
they were demoted you can't
mathematically demote everybody but the
results were magnificent within a year
we had doubled our profit without hiring
anybody and for many years afterward we
grew 20 30 40 percent a year and made
very good profit the reason is obvious
when people have complete responsibility
for their part they do very well when
they make mistakes they correct them and
the effectiveness of people in charge
feeling responsibility feeling creative
is truly impressive now one of the
warnings we had was that with the
entrepreneurial attitude where people
were competing the outs with the outside
world and competing with the Yanis other
groups inside there'd be a tendency to
sacrifice ethics in order to survive I
was surprised I must admit to find out
that to an overwhelming degree most
people want to be ethical and worked
when for an ethical company if the
standards are clear and it is honest it
is honesty and ethical activity that is
expected
people are honest when the company is
honest with them people are honest with
suppliers and customers when they
realize that the company is not
interested in short-term goals with any
other activity that might take place and
given the opportunity people are willing
to sacrifice the short-term pressures
which the financial community puts on so
strongly in order to look for the
long-term good of the company and for
society now no one ever told me the
long-term problems with entrepreneurship
and they're kind of obvious first
humility does not come easily with a
successful entrepreneur
it's almost contrary to his nature
without humility it's hard to learn and
it's hard to grow with a job secondly
with success and growth it's easy to
turn planning budgeting and financial
work over to staff and the computers an
entrepreneur without the P&L statement
his head has no power and with no power
for the frustration has put on other non
teamwork activities and then thirdly of
course an entrepreneur is the last
person on earth to give entrepreneurship
freedom to somebody else the challenge I
face today is to keep over a hundred
thousand people working together in one
direction and still maintain the
entrepreneurial spirit the challenge we
as a society have is to do that in all
our organizations
for a number of years now we in the
Western Europe we in the Western world
have been in competition with communism
our economic freedom versus their
controlled economy we won the contest
hands down no thinking person will argue
for their communist approach but yet we
won the contest and yet we're in
disarray can you imagine someone arguing
with Congress with Congress that they
want to take risks to tolerate
duplication to pay the price for
competition to give freedom to allow
people to try new ways can you imagine
newspapers allowing this to go on
without terrible criticism when business
people get together it's quite common to
snicker and laugh at the failures of
communism their central planning their
absolute intolerance of duplication or
competition their fear of risk-taking
their lack of motivation and no direct
reward devastates the Communists but
back in the American company within the
company itself
there is central planning a version the
risk-taking no duplication no
competition and rewards are not directly
tied to risk-taking
many of us as we read like to think the
go bash off would like to explore
economic freedom for his country we
realized that he has limitations he has
to convince his staff first
we wish he had more freedom the American
business leader sometimes would like to
try duplication competition internally
but as you can guess he too has staff
who are very well-educated taught all
elana little skills know how to use
computers taught to be brilliant in the
conclusions they come to but absolutely
averse to risk-taking internal
competition or any of the
entrepreneurial activities that are so
fruitful a few weeks ago I was sitting
between a minister and a translator on
the other side in the Great Hall in
China and none of the conversational was
done without going through the
translator except when I asked one
question how is it that China has gotten
so quickly from being short of food to
having a surplus of food and with that
question without the translator the
Minister came back and said we have
reforms he knew how much a farmer got
for a chicken how much a farmer got for
AG and how many chickens he needed in
order to make more than a minister made
we have very little of that spirit in
our country which claims economic
freedom I think we've demonstrated many
of you are demonstrated that people want
to run their own business who don't want
to run their own business will often
jump at the chance to take an
entrepreneurial responsibility for a
segment of a business or a school if the
goals are clear and they can take part
in the planning and I given the freedom
to take risks I wouldn't suggest that
running a business is the important
thing to do
the important thing is to make a
commitment to a job to improve things to
influence the world and I'd also suggest
that one of the most satisfying things
is to pass on to others to help others
to be creative to take responsibility to
be challenged in their job and to be
successful in that thing which is if not
the most important thing in their life
almost the most important thing sometime
hopefully long time from now
when I have to tell people it's all
yours I'm leaving they will say to me
Ken won't you stay one more year it's so
much fun so challenging to work for you
and my ambition is to leave when people
will still say that and that they'll
remember me as one who challenges them
influencing them to be creative and to
enjoy work and have fun for a long time
thank you
you